as you can imagine it's been a tense few
days after pictures of the animal went
viral and lots of people are talking
about it tonight
the sighting near hualapai way between
sahara and desert inn
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo is
live with the warning at 6.
brian and denise like you said it's
still the talk
of the town and the nevada department of
wildlife is encouraging anyone who sees
this mountain lion to please
contact authorities immediately also
keep an eye on your pets tonight
it was really big you know it was really
big so i mean i hope it's caught and
you know tranquilized a mountain lion
sighting doesn't happen
every day in the valley but every now
and then it causes concern
that i was frantic i was actually
pulling in at about three o'clock in the
morning
and when i turned into my you know
house like turning my corner i see
the mountain lion joy meadows lives in
the area of hualapai and grand canyon
she's still in shock i mean i was
terrified because you know it's a school
across the street
you know i have four four little ones at
home plus a dog
this is really their land still melissa
boy lives near durango in charleston
she found out about the sighting through
the next door app i
shared it because i'm an animal lover
and i don't want to see anybody's pets
get needlessly taken and plus
with it being a mountain lion i also
they're really they're dangerous to
humans as well
boyd remembers back in july when a
mountain lion was roaming a neighborhood
it was captured and relocated to its
original habitat their water resources
are drying up
their food voices as sources are drying
up
so they're going to be coming in where
they can get food and water
and many are still asking me if this
mountain lion we just recently saw
is the same one from last summer and the
nevada department of wildlife tells me
it's really hard to tell without dna
testing reporting live in summerlin
sally jaramillo 8 news now